Năm sẽ bọc thách trở bình sĩ về bình của sả Mỹ đã tiến và thủ đô Washington.
Đánh xấu bất hợi đau của kỹ hoại điều đồng khoảng tám chim quan đến đây.
Theo dưới trước, lực lượng này sẽ đức chiến khai bộ xung trong những người tới.
Các xe dí chuyển giữ sử hỗ tóm của Kinh San và tập kết gần đại từ nghiệm Washington.
Như vụ cũng thể chứ được công bố.
Nhà chẳng cho biết đây là một phần của chính sịch tăng cường thực tý pháp luật tại thủ đô.
Lực lượng yên bàn xếp hối hợp cùng sở Kinh San Washington để tôn tra kinh sóa,
tại những khu bận ra thông đông đốc và điểm nông an ninh.
Truy đó, tổng thống đưa nân trọng tiến bố tình chẳng thân cấp về an phần cân tận tại Washington.
Thế hoạt điều bài bốn không đạo lực tự quan.
Châu Phi em kiểm soát lực lượng cạnh xác thủ đô trong thời hạt bà mi ngài.
Lỗi bàn quý đệm mọi gia hạn sau thủ đếm ngài cân có sự chấp thận của Kinh hoại.